- Des oignons verts...
- Benoit Richard vit de plein
fouet la hausse des prix
des intrants sur sa ferme.
Engrais, semences, emballage...
tout a augmenté.
Il a choisi de ne pas vendre
ses produits à Montréal,
prix de l'essence oblige.
BENOIT RICHARD, producteur
maraîcher, Ferme Hortus
- C'est sûr que là, on reste
local, local, local.
On s'agrandit pas trop.
On a commencé les marchés,
puis on voit que les gens
sont de plus en plus réticentspé
de monter mes prix et
les gens sont pas habitués à ça.
- L'an dernier, il vendait
ses oeufs pour 3 $ la douzaine.
Il faisait 1 $ de profit.
Cette année, il doit les vendre
à 4,50 $ et fait des profits
de 30 cents. Constat similaire
chez d'autres producteurs.
EMILIE GUERARD, Propriétaire
de la boîte maraîchère
- Il y a de moins en moins
de place pour les
bénéfices, et de plus en plus
de dépenses pour tout ce qui est
intrants, matériel
de production, chas
les serres aussi, le coût
du propane, pour nous, ça a été
considérable cette année.
- Mais les producteurs
maraîchers peuvent difficilement
afficher une hausse drastique
du prix de leurs produits.
PATRICK LAUZON, Producteur
er, Fines herbes
- Parce qu'il faut quand même
rester à l'affût de tout
ce que nos compétiteurs,
ou encore les grossistes,
affichent comme prix.
- C'est du jamais-vu, selon
l'Association des producteurs
maraîchers du Québec, qui estime
entre 30 % et 50 % la hausse
des coûts de production
par rapport à l'an dernier.
PATRICE LÉGER BOURGOIN, DG, Ass.
des prod. maraîchers Bourgoin
- C'est inquiétant comme
phénomène, actuel
parce que c'est la deuxième
année de suite qu'on vit
une augmentation fulgurante
des prix des intrants.
- L'Union des producteurs
agricole demande une aide
spécifique de Québec.
- On a demandé, entre autres,une
sur un compte d'urgence
pour les entreprises agricoles,
quelque chose de rapide
pour ramener desamener desamenes
au niveau des entreprises.
- Le ministre de l'Agriculture
ne prévoit pas d'aide
supplémentaire aux programmes
déjà existants.
ANDRÉ LAMONTAGNE, ministre
Agric., s et Aliment.
- Le plan, c'est vraiment
de s'assurer que les outils
qu'on a à notre disposition
puissent très bien répondre
dans le contexte actuel.
- Comme plusieurs producteurs,
Benoit Richard compte s'adapter
aux aléas de son métier.
se qu'on va faire
assez d'argent pour survivre,
mais pas de là à pouvoir
s'acheter de la machinerie
de plus ou en profiter pour
des vacances, quoiit.
- Il garde espoir
pour des jours meilleurs.
Ici Marie-Isabelle Rochon,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.